[Música]
y extrajeras toda el agua de tu cerebro
y fraccionadas el contenido en
constituyentes nutricionales como
luciría la mayor parte del peso de tu
cerebro deshidratado provendrían de
grasa también conocidos como lípidos en
el resto de la masa cerebral
encontrarías proteínas y aminoácidos
trazas de micronutrientes y glucosa el
cerebro es por supuesto más que la suma
de sus partes nutricionales pero cada
componente tiene un claro impacto en el
funcionamiento
desarrollo estado anímico y energía la
apatía después del almuerzo o el estado
de alerta de tarde-noche que puede
sentir bueno podrían ser simplemente los
efectos de la alimentación en tu cerebro
de las grasas en el cerebro las súper
estrellas son las omega 3 y 6 estos
ácidos grasos esenciales que se han
relacionado con la prevención de
afecciones degenerativas del cerebro
deben provenir de nuestra dieta así el
consumo de alimentos ricos en omega como
frutos secos semillas y las grasas de
pescados son cruciales para crear
mantener las membranas celulares y
mientras omegas son grasas buenas para
el cerebro el consumo de largo plazo de
otras grasas como las grasas trans y
saturadas puede poner en peligro la
salud del cerebro por otra parte las
proteínas y aminoácidos los componentes
nutrientes del crecimiento y desarrollo
manipulan cómo nos sentimos y
comportamos los aminoácidos contienen
los precursores de los neurotransmisores
los mensajeros químicos que llevan
señales entre las neuronas que afectan
cosas como el estado de ánimo sueño
atención y el peso pueden ser la razón
de que sientas calma luego de un gran
plato de pasta o más alerta después de
una comida rica en proteínas las
combinaciones complejas de compuestos en
los alimentos pueden estimular las
células del cerebro a liberar
noradrenalina que altera el humor
dopamina y serotonina
pero llegar a las células del cerebro es
complicado y los aminoácidos tienen que
competir por el acceso limitado una
dieta con una gama de alimentos ayuda a
mantener una combinación equilibrada de
mensajeros cerebrales y evita que tu
estado de ánimo se incline en una
dirección u otra como los otros órganos
de nuestro cuerpo nuestro cerebro se
beneficia de un abasto constante de
micronutrientes los antioxidantes en las
frutas y verduras apoyan al cerebro en
su lucha contra los radicales libres que
destruyen neuronas lo que permite a tu
cerebro a trabajar bien por un período
de tiempo más largo y sin
micronutrientes poderosos como las
vitaminas b6 y b12 y el ácido fólico
nuestro cerebro serían susceptibles a la
enfermedad cerebral y deterioro mental
trazas de los minerales hierro cobre
zinc y sodio son también esenciales para
la salud del cerebro y el desarrollo
cognitivo temprano para que el cerebro
transforme y sintetiza de manera
eficiente estos nutrientes valiosos
necesita combustible y mucho de él
aunque el cerebro humano sólo es cerca
del 2% de nuestro peso corporal utiliza
hasta un 20 por ciento de nuestros
recursos energéticos la mayor parte de
esta energía proviene de los
carbohidratos que nuestro cuerpo digiere
en glucosa o azúcar en la sangre los
lóbulos frontales son tan sensibles a
las caídas en la glucosa de hecho que un
cambio en la función mental es una de
las señales primarias de la deficiencia
de nutrientes
suponiendo que recibimos glucosa con
regularidad cómo afecta a nuestro
cerebro el tipo específico de
carbohidratos que comemos los
carbohidratos se presentan en tres
formas almidón azúcar y fibra aunque en
la mayoría de las etiquetas de nutrición
se agrupa al total de hidratos de
carbono la proporción de azúcar y los
subgrupos de fibra en el total afecta a
la forma en que el cuerpo y el cerebro
responden alimentos con alto contenido
glucémico como el pan blanco causan una
liberación rápida de la glucosa en la
sangre y luego viene una caída el azúcar
en la sangre cae y con ella nuestra
capacidad de atención y ánimo por otro
lado la avena granos y legumbres tienen
la liberación de glucosa más lenta que
permiten un nivel más constante de
atención para mantener el poder cerebral
opta por una dieta variada de alimentos
ricos en nutrientes es fundamental
cuando se trata de lo que muerde más
pica si tragas tus decisiones tienen un
efecto directo y de larga duración en el
órgano más poder en tu cuerpo
porque tu cerebro piensa que la lengua
se quema al morder algo picante explora
la ciencia de los condimentos picantes
con este vídeo y asegúrate de
suscribirte a nuestro canal para ver mas
tdt en español
nunca